hallo meine lieben freunde herzlich
hallo und herzlich willkommen zu einer
neuen folge der minecraft mods wo ich
wollte wirklich aus minecraft sag mir wo
die reine coole mode phoebe und züge
sind zwar ist es sicher die kurze
simpelste und allgemeinen und
kreativsten modifikation die ich euch
hier vor dem verzehr gewarnt meiner
liebe vielleicht können sich einige noch
daran erinnern ich hab mal in einer
crafting ideas folge sagt er
der schwer noch voll cool dem endlichen
obsidian boot machen könnte und damit
dann übers wasser fahren könnte und so
ihr habt dem titel gelesen ihr habt es
offene gesehen und jetzt habt ihr es
auch ihr das ist die obsidian bot
modifikations einzige was wir machen
müssen um so ein ob sie die am boot zu
bekommen ist quasi einfach so ein boot
machen aus obsidian dann bekommt man
dieses obsidian boot und mir wurde jetzt
halt diese wurde ich bin einfach von
extrem vielen leuten unter diese
crafting ads folge geschrieben
du bist ja vielleicht kommen wir ja gar
kein skelett folio das ist einfach ein
zombie pacman ja und zwar wir sind erst
bei einer mod vorstellung und zwar so
simpel die modifikation noch ist ich
bleibe beim thema und zwar fügt diese
modifikation wirklich nur dieses eine
rezept hinzu dass man mit fünf jahren
ein obsidian boot machen kann das kann
ich jetzt auf lager setzen setzt mich da
rein und ich kann damit jetzt überall
aber fahren das war vor hinter so ein
bisschen langsamer als noch so halb auf
diesem level rector stand aber an sich
funktioniert das ganze wie normales brot
ich finde sogar man kann viel besser
steuern und das cool ist es kommen sogar
partikel also es sieht wirklich extrem
geil aus und ich kann damit sogar
rückwärts fahren wenn ich jetzt die demo
gegen gefahren und außerdem ist dieses
boot komplett resistent wenn ich jetzt
hier mal beispielsweise irgendwo gegen
fahrer also das geht nicht irgendwie die
einzelteile kaputt wenn ich jetzt hier
gegen fahrer oder sowie ein ganz
normales holzboot und zwar ganz einfach
dann würde ich das sterben wenn ich
jetzt hier irgendwo gegen fahren würde
will ich sterben das wäre zu hohes
risiko dann könnte ich alle meine sachen
verlieren und erwarte ich versuche ich
versuche mal durch diesen kleinen spalt
hier durch das wehr übels genial an
da komme ich nicht so ich brauche doch
schon zwei platz habe ich jetzt zwei
platz jetzt gehe ich mal eben durch kann
ich hier dann in kleiner runde drehen
und ich finde die lenkung ist halt schon
viel besser ich kann hier so ein
bisschen
kann ich ja warum wenn wir die rechte
thema anschaut das geht extrem gut also
ich kann hier wirklich die partikel sind
alle da das sieht richtig cool aus und
ich fühle mich eigentlich schon so ein
bisschen grad wie sonnenbraut sollen ich
denke die meisten hier halten nicht so
viel von der modifikation weil zeit
einfach nur einen gegen standen zufügt
einfach nur sein ob sie die angebote
hinzu aber es ist eine modifikation die
für die 1.7 funktion fertig ist und
gerade für die 1.8 updated wird das
heißt für alle diese single playlist
bermann ich bin auf jeden fall die
modifikation reinpacken
weil sein ob sie die am boden über lava
zu fahren ist schon extrem cool finde
ich übrigens werden einige hier
ich bin gerade in den netto erst rein
gegangen ich bin direkt hier bei zu
einer festung geht's da oben rechts und
gerade diese türme also wenn jemand von
euch den zieht möchte bzw
die koordinaten so bin ich hier gerade
im netz 8 die koordinaten die sind ja
doch das kann sich ganz gut merken hier
im netz eine festung also keine ahnung
ob es euch interessiert ich finde es
eigentlich ganz cool dafür dass es
wirklich wirklich wirklich wirklich
denke dass dieses video eine menge des
sex bekommen wird einfach weil es halt
wirklich noch ein item entwickelt sich
so eine krasse modifikation ist mit 20
milliarden neue mops und sowas allem
aber deswegen habe ich mir einfach
gedacht hey ich lade einfach mal zwei
videos hoch zwar halt einmal jetzt
irgendwie gerade keine ahnung wie viel
übers grad ist 14.30 15.00 den dreh dich
dann einmal diesem motto und dann kommt
heute abend dann irgendwie noch wenn ich
schaffe eine runde hashtag fragt luca
einfach so dann habe ich so zwei kleine
videos von heute anstatt zu 1 anstatt zu
einem folgeroman oder irgendwas ruhig
echtem extrem lang dran sitze ich habe
einfach gedacht ich zeige euch das mal
dass es sowas sonne kräftig idee halt
wirklich nicht nur ideen sondern
teilweise wirklich umgesetzt werden das
ist richtig geil und ich würde sagen es
euch trotzdem gefallen haben wobei ein
bewertung von unten und von beim
nächsten check wie die partie